nous sommes avec laurent alexandre
essayiste et she revient bonsoir laurent
alexandre merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés pour en débattre frédéric bizarre
économiste de la santé bonsoir à vous
aussi frédéric bizarre merci d'être avec
nous alors je me tourne tout d'abord
vers vous docteur pour commencer avec
évidemment cette annonce spectaculaire
avec 5 qui serait fiable à 90%
on les entend déjà les critiques
notamment sur la fiabilité des données
scientifiques
qu'est ce qu'ils en aient vous quel a
été votre réaction à ces résultats sont
encourageants - c'est la première fois
qu'on a des résultats sur un vaccin
alors ce ne sont pas des résultats
définitifs pour l'instant il n'y a pas
suffisamment de recul on manque encore
de quelques semaines deux semaines de
recul pour voir trancher donc l'essai
clinique manque à ce stade de puissance
statistique ce sont des résultats
intermédiaires comme le président de
pfizer l'a très bien expliqué lors de sa
conférence de presse de son communiqué
cela dit ce sont quand même des
résultats encourageants il faut les
confirmés et puis je partage tout à fait
le point de vue de mon collègue gilbert
de rennes dans ses interrogations
quelle est la durée de la protection est
ce que les formes graves sont aussi
protégés éviter et puis aussi un point
très important
les malades qui évite la maladie en fait
les patients potentiels qui évite la
maladie grâce au vaccin
est-ce qu'ils sont seulement protégé e
où est-ce qu'ils sont aussi il évite
aussi de contaminer les autres
autrement dit est-ce que le vaccin et
stérilisant c'est-à-dire qu'ils
protègent les individus et en plus ils
évitent la transmission vers d'autres
malades donc toutes ces questions se
posent
elles vont doivent d'être tranchée dans
les semaines qui viennent
de toute façon nous ne disposerons pas
massivement du vaccin avant février mars
parce que les délais de fabrication et
de diffusion sont longs il ne faut pas
qu il ne faut pas oublier que ce vaccin
est une première c'est un vaccin arn et
la rn et fragile donc il va falloir
conserver le vaccin entre moins 70 c'est
moins 80 degrés donc la diffusion la
distribution de vaccins ne va pas
pouvoir se faire comme d'habitude
par les médecins et par l'est et par les
pharmaciens dans certains pays il va
falloir une distribution centralisée
il n'y a que les centres de recherche
les hôpitaux et les cliniques qui
dispose de frigidaire à -70 ça moins 80
degrés qui vont pouvoir conserver le
virus et donc le distribuer et lino culé
aux patients dans l'hypothèse que tout
le monde espère ou ce vaccin sera
effectivement efficace comme les données
préliminaires d'hier semblent le montrer
frédéric bizarre on l'a entendu
également confirmation de la bouche de
laurent alexandre qui connaît bien le
sujet encore beaucoup de deux questions
des essais qui ne sont pas totalement
terminé des études scientifiques qui
pour le moment
voilà donc pas suivi c'est un communiqué
de la part des laboratoires qu'on croit
finalement sur parole c était normal
d'en parler dès maintenant selon vous
alors on peut se poser la question
pourquoi est ce que pfizer se
précipitent un petit peu avant le lock
tension des résultats définitifs je
pourrais en dire un mot tout à l'heure
cela dit je partage et on peut saluer le
succès on devrait dire sur le plan
technologique c'est une avancée
scientifique majeure c'est une nouvelle
forme de vaccin arn messagers on n'a
jamais eu jusqu'à maintenant avec ce 1
er m message est donc à partir de
biotechnologie du génie génétique à
rester accès plus la même façon de
fabriquer un vaccin et c'est d'ailleurs
le succès de la biotechnologie en
général par rapport aux grandes big
pharma s'est pas le succès des big
pharmas c'est le succès des jeunes
sociétés des jeunes pousses de
biotechnologie puisqu'on voit à biot
wintek on voit curva convoi moderna sait
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont sur le devant la
scène c'est pas sanofi s'est pas
fighters c'est pas faiseur n'est que le
distributeur dans cette affaire là donc
ça c'est quelque chose quand même qui
est intéressant et qui montre qu'on est
en train de changer d'air y compris pour
la vaccination donc ça à mon avis et
c'est une c'est ce qu'il ya d'important
dans cette nouvelle tâche même si on
verra on n'est pas capable aujourd'hui
d'évaluer avec les données qui ont été
présentés véritablement la force de la
protection qui est apportée mais je
pense qu'on peut saluer ce succès là
maintenant pourquoi est-ce-que files
heures un petit peu se précipitent
c'est parce que c'est une course c'est
une course contre la montre mais c'est
une course entre les laboratoires
c'est à dire qu'on est ce qu'on va
essayer de stimuler un maximum de près
comment on a toutes les précommandes qui
on est et qui auront été conclu ça ne
sera pas conclue avec les autres en tout
cas on prend on prend de l'avancé par
rapport à ça maintenant il faut savoir
qu'il ya des facteurs limitants
absolument essentiel et je pense que ça
ne changera rien pour au moins les six
mois voire l'année kiki qui est devant
nous faut pour la france
pour des questions de limitation de
production pour des cons c'est qu'il ya
des des composantes notamment des
enzymes laurent alexandre connaissez
mieux que moi pour produire ces vaccins
là où qui font que le 1 milliard 300
millions de doses qui est annoncé mais
me paraît difficile dit difficilement
crédible on sait qu'il faut construire
ses usines de production il ya très peu
aujourd'hui qui existent vous pouvez pas
transformer des usines qui fabriquent
aujourd'hui des vaccins adénovirus rang
des usines en tout cas vous ne pouvez
pas le faire du jour au lendemain donc
tout ça va entraîner des délais qui font
que probablement il y as falloir
attendre fin 2021 mais ce qui n'empêche
que avec l'hypothèse que ce vaccin soit
efficace de façon suffisante
c'est un arsenal qui se remplit par
rapport à ce qu vide et qui devrait nous
aider à aller vers cette immunité de
groupe puisqu'on voit que
malheureusement ce virus est là pour
durer dans notre environnement
donc il va falloir ramener de l'ensemble
des populations vers cette immunité
ocz et ça sera une arme probablement
très intéressante à moyen terme laurent
alexandre a justement parlé de ces doses
par milliards certainement nécessaire
l'union européenne qui d'ores et déjà on
le sait va signer 300 millions de doses
en précommande
alors qu'on a toujours ces questions
dont on parle depuis le début de ce
débat en suspens pourquoi autant de de
confiance parce que ce sont les états
unis l'allemagne
c'est sur parole finalement cette
efficacité ou les études on était quand
même suffisamment sérieuse on a on a on
a pas le choix
le confinement les gens n'en veulent
plus aucun médicament antiviral n'a fait
la preuve de son efficacité l'hydroxyde
chloroquine ne marche pas le renne désir
ne marche pas l'interféron ne marche pas
le pi navire ne marchait pas donc aucun
des quatre groupes d'antiviraux qu'on a
testé le fonctionnent donc on n'a pas de
mai
comment certes la réanimation de ne pas
trop mauvais résultats et la mortalité
des gens qui ont des cowboys grave a été
divisé par deux depuis le printemps mais
on n'a toujours pas de traitement donc
nous sommes bien obligés de croire dans
le vaccin est et en plus on ne voit pas
arriver de médicaments antiviraux dans
les 12 à 18 mois qui viennent donc la
seule carte qu'on a à jouer
à moins d'avoir une récession mondiale
grave et bien ou à cause d'un
confinement généralisée que les
populations ne vont plus supporter la
seule carte qu'on peut jouer c'est le
vaccin il ya une dizaine de vaccins à
l'heure actuelle qui sont en phase iii
celui de pfizer et le plus avancé
les données sont intéressantes mais
elles doivent être confirmées
alors il est peu probable que le
président de pfizer est menti pour une
raison très simple c'est que le gendarme
de la bourse aux états unis et d'une
sévérité extraordinaire et donc la sca
qui vérifie la véracité des déclarations
des entreprises cotées à la bourse de
new york
eh bien elle ne laisserait pas passer
une fausse déclaration
car une fausse déclaration une
déclaration propos petit mist du
président de pfizer hier serait en
réalité une manipulation de cours et le
gendarme boursier américain sanctionne
ça de façon dramatiquement méchante
alors effectivement justement vous
passait très bien le plat laurent
alexandre fisc américain blizzard
l'économiste que vous êtes ça ne vous a
pas échappé ses actions ce a donné le
sourire à la bourse des actions
notamment d'air france de renault et les
compagnies qui pâtissent beaucoup de
cette crise sont remontés comme par
enchantement quel est le constat de
l'économie s'il ya beaucoup évidemment
de d'argent en jeu bien évidemment
autour d'un vaccin comme ça je suis pas
sûr que rolf schnyder ne fait pas des
révélations comme ça là à
l'emporte-pièce et autres c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement sérieux maintenant
files heures si vous regardez bien
un petit peu ce communiqué de presse qui
est relativement court divulguent des
informations qui nous permettent pas
d'en savoir énormément et de tirer des
conclusions
on ne sait pas exactement sur quelle
tranche d'âge c'est efficace on ne
connaît pas la nature de la protection
je crois que gilbert de rennes d'un
hôtel ans en tweed bon donc
donc il ne ment pas simplement il nous
donne juste une bribe d'information pour
nous dire c'est probablement que ça va
marcher mais est-ce que ça va marcher
dans des proportions importantes dans
des proportions relativement faible 90 %
est à prendre c'est un chiffre très
élevé et un ça qui est vraiment le truc
mais mais mais on peut pas en tirer des
conclusions sur la la force de la
protection définitive
voilà on va pas entrer dans le détail
mais c'est une chose ça je pense que ces
matches pourquoi est-ce que file vers le
fait encore une fois c'est parce qu'il
ya des parts de marché à prendre parce
qu'il va avoir des concurrents sur la
même technologie et donc il ya des parts
de marché à prendre le plus tôt possible
à partir du moment où vous avez signé
des pré commandes avec les états avec
l'union européenne avec les états unis
mais vous avez pris ses parts de marché
avant les les concurrents bon donc c'est
une face ça me paraît une logique assez
assez naturel vous pouvez passer un
certain nombre d'accords plus tôt que
les autres
je crois que dieu une tech a passé des
accords avec fosun en chine donc vous
pouvez accélérer un peu le développement
du business plus rapidement que les
autres qui attendent le résultat avant
de pouvoir passer à cette phase de
développement
c'est assez naturel il ya rien de neuf
extrêmement choquant faut juste pas trop
naïf par rapport à ce qui se passe et
c'est un as et un effet collatéral 1
d'abord on est un peu dans une
exubérance irrationnelle de la bourse
qui a encensé des valeurs liées au
tourisme
alors que franchement le tourisme
risquent pas de reprendre avant 2022 ait
compris avec la sortie de ce vaccin bon
mais c'est comme ça c'est la logique de
greenspan sur l'exubérance de la bourse
en tout cas le pas parole du
gouvernement reste lui aussi prudent et
d'être au part j'imagine que les les
français voilà en tire des conclusions
un peu trop hâtif peut-être je vous
propose d'écouter gabriela talent c'est
toujours encourageant
mais qu'il faut être d'une très grande
prudence dès lors que les données
scientifiques ne sont pas connus dès
lors que l'ensemble des essais et des
tests n'ont pas été réalisés il faut
être extrêmement transparent aussi
devant les français pour leur dire que
le vaccin ne pourra pas être une
solution à la deuxième vague que nous
vivons c'est important de le rappeler et
de le dire de la prudence quand même un
laurent alexandre de la part du porte
parole de gouvernement alors on parle
quand même de tester vacciner toute la
population d'ailleurs le vert 1 yannick
jadot veut lui déjà rendre obligatoire
ce vaccin votre sentiment là tu es ce
qu'on a les moyens les structures et
puis aussi qui va payer en toujours la
même chose alors le vaccin sera
remboursé par la sécurité sociale à à
100% donc je ne me fais mais la vrai nom
il est payé franchement pas très cher
par rapport à ce que coûte une journée
en réanimation quand les gens font écho
villegats grave
le vaccin est vraiment pas cher du tout
la question qui va se poser c qui
faut-il vacciner
est-ce qu'il faut vacciner uniquement
les 25 millions de personnes âgées de
baisse de diabétiques et de malades
présentant une pathologie associée
risque de grave qui risque de faire un
kobe grave ou est-ce qu'il faut vacciner
plus largement personnellement compte
tenu de la très faible mortalité chez
les jeunes et même si les jeunes peuvent
transmettre le virus je serais plutôt
partisan de vacciner 20 à 25 millions de
personnes âgées de personnes à risque je
ne suis pas favorable à une
généralisation est une obligation
vaccinale chez les moins de 60 ans
frédéric bizarre on va terminer avec un
sondage ipsos sur justement le
scepticisme de certains français on
connaît le sujet parker sur les vaccins
regardez sur dix-huit mille personnes
interrogées dans 15 pays 73% sont prêts
à se faire vacciner en france seulement
54% des sondés souhaitent
se soumettre à ce vaccin le plus bas du
classement et a toujours ce scepticisme
frédéric bizarre ça vous étonne non
parce qu on connait enfin franchement
quand on voit ce qui reste des libertés
de ce qu'on fait des libertés
individuelles de la responsabilité
individuelle dans ce pays
avec ce confinement ce genre de
déclaration est d'abord une
méconnaissance complète de la santé
publique la santé publique n'a pas
vocation à être liberticide
la santé publique est faite sur de la
sueur de l'éducation sur de la pédagogie
sur de l'incitation
nous sommes le seul pays au monde avec
l'italie mais qui a arrêté à rendre
obligatoire dans les pays démocratiques
j'entends à rendre obligatoire la
vaccination depuis deux ans tellement on
a échoué
on atterrit santé publique la france a
organisé la santé autour des individus
il faut maintenant qu'elle organise
autour de la population il faut passer
du soin à la santé publique
c'est une évolution de notre système
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre plutôt
que de faire des déclarations et je suis
d'accord avec laurent alexandre il va
falloir cible est probablement une
population et la boucle de soutien plus
à risque et le faire sur une base
d'incitation enfin chacun aura
évidemment compris qu'il a plutôt
intérêt à se protéger à protéger
pourquoi les français seraient moins
enclins à protéger d autant parler
d'épidémie
c'est tout simplement savait plus vous
contraignez c'est la meilleure façon de
favoriser les campagnes anti vaccins si
vous commencez à contraindre et obliger
les gens vont se dire où l'art
il doit y avoir un loup parce que si on
n'est pas capable de m'expliquer
pourquoi par moi même avec mon
intelligent je dois réaliser une
démarche c'est que probablement il doit
y avoir un risque dans cette démarche
alors qu'il n'y en a quasiment pas
laurent alexandre le mot de la fin sur
cette défiance des français envers le
vaccin c'est tout simplement une
défiance envers les pouvoirs publics en
qu'elles ne font peut-être penser c'est
très étrange
la france le pays de pasteur le pays qui
a beaucoup développé les vaccins à la
fin du 19e siècle est le pays le plus
sceptique vis des vaccins et c'est en
france d'ailleurs qu'il y a le plus fort
courant complotistes anti vaccins donc
là il ya une réflexion collective qu'on
doit avoir
pourquoi la france qui était un pays
scientifique extraordinaire est en train
de devenir un pays technophobes
anti-science anti technologies
anti-vaccins personnellement et c'est un
sujet connexe ça ne concerne pas les
vaccins j'ai été bouleversé par le fait
en savants comme cédric villani soit
devenue maintenant anti science et
s'oppose à la 5g avec des arguments
absolument incompréhensible
notre place politique favori cette
défiance des français vis à vis de la
science et on le voit au travers de la 5
v li aujourd'hui et est bannie par
beaucoup d'hommes politiques qui
considèrent qu'elle est nocive et on est
le seul pays au monde où il ya un
courant de défiance le contre la
technologie 5 g donc ce n'est pas
spécifique aux vaccins la france est en
train de devenir un paradis pour les
obscurantistes et un enfer pour les gens
qui aiment la science et la rationalité
merci beaucoup laurent alexandre
essayiste et chirurgie remercie
également avoue frédéric bizarre
économiste de la santé merci à tous les
deux